as tom brady put on his seventh super
bowl ring
many people began calling him the
greatest athlete of all time
but some feminists dispute that claim
they argue
that serena williams the tennis player
has won more championships
and therefore she is the greatest
athlete of all time
now i think it's ridiculous to compare
male and female
athletes to one another but even just
looking at the female athletes
have these people never heard of caitlyn
jenner caitlin's amazing
not only did she win the decathlon but
she even beat
all the men doing it we'll get into all
sorts of national games i'm michael
knowles this is the michael and old show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from trey best
who says the fact that liz cheney uh
says
that the fact that trump was impeached
in a bipartisan fashion
is just her saying the fact that i voted
for it
is the reason that we should now listen
to her yes this is this is basically
true
liz cheney comes out and she says look
the impeachment of trump it was
bipartisan
and you say well hold on it was by it
seemed like it was
like 211 republicans voted
uh against it and like 10 of you voted
for it that is that by i don't know
that's bipartisan that doesn't that
doesn't seem right
to me that i i don't i don't buy that uh
but that is her argument because i am
working with the democrats therefore
we should all work with the democrats
because i am more liberal therefore we
should all be
more liberal and unfortunately for now
it seems to have
worked we need some security against
these sorts of
uh machinations and politics one great
way to get security is with lifelock
this year saw many cyber security
attacks including data breaches network
infiltrations bulk data theft and sale
identity theft and ransomware attacks
the largest shift of employees working
remotely has coincided
with an increase in attacks a recent
study suggests
that remote workers have become the
source of up to 20
of cyber security incidents that
occurred in 2020.
good thing there's lifelock lifelock is
a leader in identity theft protection
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised
they will send you an alert i know what
you're thinking you're thinking
no one's after my data no come on it
doesn't matter i can go online no
do not leave yourself so vulnerable no
one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
lifelock can see threats that you might
miss on your own
join now and save up to 25 percent off
your first year go to lifelock.com
knowles know wles that is lifelock.com
knowles
for 25 off go check out lifelock
highly recommend it when you go online
make sure you are using
lifelock
did i say something wrong with regard to
serena williams and caitlyn jenner
did what what did i say that was wrong
because i have been told time and time
and time again
i was just told this by the aclu we'll
get to it in a moment
that trans women are women i've been
just been told by the biden
administration
that trans women you know who maybe they
look like men maybe they have a bit of a
husky voice maybe they've got an adam's
apple and other
male appendages but very pronounced you
know
i won't get into it however they're
women that's what i've been told
so if that is the case then caitlyn
jenner is the greatest
female athlete of all time there's no
question serena williams couldn't beat
all the men in the decathlon there's no
chance
now the left believes
they say that they believe that that men
can become women right that
trans women are women but none of them
believe that
we should call caitlyn jenner the
greatest athlete of all time and by the
way
you might you might say this is this is
one objection i've heard but only from
knuckle-dragging conservatives
they say well no no caitlyn jenner
didn't win the decathlon bruce jenner
won the decathlon but now bruce jenner
no longer exists and bruce jenner's
caitlyn
jenner no that's not what they believe
go read the wikipedia page
read the arthur courage award
description that that caitlyn jenner won
they believe the left and the
transgender ideologues believe
that bruce jenner never really existed
bruce was always caitlyn he was always a
woman trapped in a man's body and
therefore
those accomplishments go to to bruce
now the reason i bring this up at all is
a democratic congressman very radical
guy from new york jamal bowman
listed trying to attack tom brady he
says
you know kind of forget about tom brady
the greatest athletes of all time are
one muhammad ali
two serena williams three tiger woods
um come again
number two is the big issue here i won't
take issue with muhammad ali or even
tiger woods at the moment but i will
take issue with serena williams
she's obviously not the greatest athlete
of all time because men are better
athletes than women
doesn't mean that that women's tennis
can't be an interesting thing to watch
especially when serena williams is
screaming at the referees
but it's just to say that the men are
stronger they're faster they're bigger
than women this is just a fact
we know that this is the case because
serena williams herself
uh in the late 1990s had a battle of the
sexes where she said she thought she
could beat a man who was ranked outside
the top 200.
so very famously a player named carsten
baraj
who is ranked i think 203 or 208 decided
he would play serena williams
before their match he prepared by
playing a round of golf
smoking a bunch of cigarettes and
tossing back a few adult beverages
he then beat uh one he actually played
back-to-back games with both williams
sisters
he beat one of them six to one he beat
the next one six to two
it's just a fact of biology men men are
better
at sports uh we're not allowed to say
this though
though now we're having these debates
about the the transgender
games and you have even many feminists
coming out and saying
wait a second these men who now identify
as women have an unfair advantage well
the aclu is here to tell you that's
completely fake
there is no advantage whatsoever this is
the aclu of south dakota apparently not
the cleverest
aclu chapter they have an article out
debunking the myths
fueling anti-trans legislation
this is because south dakota lawmakers
are trying to ban
men from playing in women's sports uh so
they have these these myths that they're
busting in these facts
myth the participation of trans athletes
hurts cis women
fact including trans athletes
will benefit everyone okay
um well what's the argument for that
it's kind of interesting too in this
article they put the fact
first because they want you to read that
top line so it looks it it's very
confusing because it seems that their
their
says that we're going to debunk these
things and they say debunking including
trans athletes will benefit everyone it
sounds like it's kind of actually the
opposite article than it is
again more evidence that they're not the
brightest bulbs in the pack there
because their evidence is
many who oppose the inclusion of trans
athletes erroneously claim
that allowing trans athletes to compete
will harm cisgender women
this divide and conquer tactic gets it
exactly wrong
excluding women who are trans hurts all
women it invites gender policing that
could subject any woman to invasive
tests
or accusations of being too masculine or
too good
at their sport to be a real woman
further this myth reinforces stereotypes
that those who identify as women are
weak and in need of protection
and then it kind of follows that down a
little bit too now
they're they're making they're kind of
highlighting all of these these talking
points these left-wing talking points
but it they never address the actual
claim which is
that the the trans athletes are
stronger faster bigger right and
therefore they'll beat the women
they never address that anywhere in the
debunking aspect
another one fact trans athletes do not
have an unfair advantage in sports
this is answering the myth according to
the aclu the trans athletes
physiological characteristics provide an
unfair advantage over cis athletes
now listen to their evidence here women
and girls who are trans face
discrimination and violence that makes
it difficult to remain in school
according to the u.s trans survey 22
percent of trans women
who were perceived as trans in school
were harassed so badly they had to leave
school because of it
another 10 were kicked out of school the
idea that women and girls have an
advantage because they are trans ignores
the actual condition of their lives
that's not what we're talking about
nobody is saying
that the myth they're debunking is not
that men who identify as women
aren't bullied the myth they're
debunking allegedly
is that the men are physically stronger
they know they don't even begin to
address that
the rest of the article goes on in
exactly the same way
it's very very strange to me
that anybody could possibly believe
this ideology
you know i gave a couple years ago when
this really was cropping up
i had a speaking tour and one of the
speeches on the tour was men are not
women
and other uncomfortable truths and i was
i was physically attacked
because i gave this speech and at the
time it didn't make sense but it's
starting to make sense to me
it's starting to make sense because
the problem is well one you have to not
believe your own lying eyes right to
believe that like
billy you know who now goes by bethany
is uh not physically stronger than
an actual woman but the other reason is
because these two aspects of leftist
ideology
contradict one another on the one hand
uh the
the lg part of lgbt we're told
you are born with certain sexual
orientations and attractions
you can't change them right i'm born
this way no one would choose to be born
this way that was what they said in the
90s now they don't really say that
anymore
but you know because sex and sexual
orientation is immutable
therefore we ought to tolerate sort of
homosexual attractions and relationships
okay makes perfect sense to me
but then at the same time they say also
there's no such thing as sex
there's no such thing as gender
everything's changeable nothing is
immutable
and men can actually become women he
said well that doesn't make any sense
if there's no such thing as immutable
sex
innate sex then
there is no such thing as l or g andrew
sullivan a gay guy
wrote an essay about this just a few
years ago
how on earth will we resolve this
problem
a lot of conservatives say that the
transgender activism
is is going to sort of finally awaken
many leftists to the
incoherence of some of their ideology
i don't think so anymore i don't think
that's true because i was recently
rereading george orwell
and and george orwell describes this
process exactly he says
at the heart of the regime the dystopian
regime that he's describing
is doublethink and what doublethink is
is the ability to hold two contradictory
ideas
in your mind at the same time
right western philosophy is going
all the way back to dear old uncle
aristotle is based on the idea that you
can't do that
or that or rather that the you know a
thing cannot be
what it is and not what it is at the
same time
non-contradiction but double think in
the dystopian regime of george orwell
is this idea that actually a thing can
be one thing and it's opposite
or end something different at the same
time and
this is how they maintain power because
what we are told by orwell is that
if you have double think if you're
holding two contradictory ideas at the
same time
then you are unwilling or un and unable
to think very deeply about a lot of
ideas
i think that is what the left is is
banking on
i i i don't think that
this contradiction is is a bug of
political correctness
or of leftism i think it's a feature
i think it is a way to undermine our
confidence in reason
or to undermine our confidence and
objective truth this is this is what the
left has been pushing for a long time do
you remember when the smithsonian
institution
put out a flyer about a year or so ago
saying that rational thought and
objective reality
is a characteristic of whiteness and we
need to get rid of it
and here is sort of an offensive flyer
that they put out
but it but it's all part and parcel of
the same
the same ideology i'm i'm no longer
confident
that uh leftism political correctness
locus whatever you want to call it
is going to undo itself on on its own
uh contradictions because the
contradictions are the point
we're still dealing in the realm of
logic but what what these kind of
ideologies are doing is trying to under
undermine
our confidence in reason and logic
which makes me just want to get out of
dodge you know makes me want to get out
of town one great way to do it it's with
your rad power bike
whether you want a new way to get around
town or get out of town get out in
nature
even with the kids in tow you've got to
try rad power bikes it is a cross
between a traditional bike
and a moped but it doesn't require a
special driver's license like a moped
would
go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling so you can get out and about
without getting sweaty
rad power bikes are affordable most
e-bikes are in the three thousand dollar
range
rad power bikes start at just 999
dollars and most
are under fifteen hundred dollars do you
have questions rad power bikes has
dedicated
us-based customer support i love that
us-based
customer support one of the sweet
privileges when you can find it
one of the true luxuries go get it you
want a real luxury rad power bikes they
are absolutely fabulous
for a limited time rad power bikes
offers flexible financing
for as low as zero percent apr plus free
shipping
bikes are going super fast so make sure
you order right away text knowles
kenneth wles
to 64 000 today and get free shipping
that is knowles canada wles
to 64 000 text knolls to 64 000.
go check out rad powerbike's terrific
terrific product
speaking of leftist doublethink jen
saki our favorite white house press
secretary of the biden administration
the only white house press secretary of
the biden administration
is facing some tough questions only from
from one reporter
peter ducey who's clearly a little more
right-leaning
joe biden promised before the election
that he would not destroy union jobs
then his policies have already destroyed
a lot of union jobs
joe biden promises don't worry you're
going to get better jobs you're going to
get green jobs you're going to get super
duper jobs sometime in the future
peter ducey asks jen saki to explain
just when those jobs are going to show
up
fossil fuel industry workers whether
it's pipeline workers or construction
workers
who are either out of work or will soon
be out of work because of a vitamin eo
when it is and where it is that they can
go for their green job
well i'd certainly welcome you to
present your data of all the thousands
and thousands of people who
won't be getting a green job maybe next
time you're here you can present that
you said that they would be getting
green jobs so i'm just asking when that
happened
richard trumka who is a friend long time
friend of joe biden says
about that day one keystone eo he says i
wish
he the president had paired that more
carefully with the thing that he did
second by saying
here's where we are creating the jobs so
there's partial evidence from richard
trunka well
you didn't include all of his interview
would you like to include the rest
so how about this uh the laborers
international union of north america
said the keystone decision will cost
one thousand existing union jobs and ten
thousand projected construction jobs
well what mr chompaga also indicated in
the same interview was that president
biden has proposed a climate plan with
transformative investments in
infrastructure
okay there's a whole lot there there's
no answer she at no point does she
answer the question
but there is a whole lot there to
dissect because
peter ducey asks the simple question
biden is costing people costing these
sort of workers at least 10 11 000 jobs
probably more
when are they going to get the jobs that
are going to replace them and
jen saki gives this glib answer because
she's she's just
known for her glibness for sort of
brushing it off dismissing things
oh yes space force yeah it's the air
flight of the future hahaha now we're
asking you serious questions
so the question is when are they going
to get their job she says well
um if you want to prove to me that
they're not going to get their jobs
maybe you can do that next time peter
ducey says that's
that's not at all at all what i asked
the premise of my question is not that
they're never going to get the jobs i'm
asking you the person responsible
for communicating this policy when they
will get the jobs that
you have already promised he says you
know even the head of
richard trumka the head of the afl cio
the you know biggest labor union in
america
he he is saying you know where's the
jobs
now then she because she at least
remembers the trumka quote
she says well did you finish the quote
he says
yeah you know the jobs haven't
materialized she goes no but the rest of
the quote
peter is that he knows that joe biden
has a plan
and so at the end of all of that we've
got how long was that answer that back
and forth that whole exchange
we have no answer the the starting point
of the question was joe biden says he
has a plan
but when is that plan going to
materialize the ending point after all
that little
back and forth debate is
he has a plan what's the plan
when's it going to happen this this was
not a conversation this is like
just blather uh masquerading his
conversation so ducey to his credit
pushes
one more time he tries to get an answer
out of jen saki
there are people living paycheck to
paycheck there are now people out of job
once the keystone pipe out of jobs once
the keystone pipeline uh
stopped construction spent 12 days since
gina mccarthy and john kerry were here
and it's been 19
days since that eel so what are these
people who need money now
when do they get their green jobs well
the president and many democrats and
republicans in congress
believe that investment in
infrastructure building infrastructure
that's international interests and the
boosts the us economy creates
good paying union jobs here in america
and advances our climate and clean
energy goals are
something that we can certainly work on
doing together and he has every plan to
share more about his uh details of that
plan in the weeks ahead oh good he's got
a plan
to announce the plan and look
infrastructure
in infrastruct what what are you talking
about you're just saying
words you're just a very specific
question
where are these union energy jobs gonna
what's gonna happen with them
uh uh you know um
plans strategies plans
no answer uh this is in part because jen
saki is
actually worse at her job than her
predecessors and probably joe biden
should have picked uh
tj ducklow his uh communications guy
from the campaign trail i don't just say
this because we bear a passing
resemblance to one another
but saki's really really given weak
sauce here but it's not entirely saki's
fault
the biden administration also has no
answer now
speaking of paychecks and policy i
something very strange has happened over
the past few days mitt romney
has proposed legislation first of all
very few senators actually propose any
legislation anymore
mitt romney has done it and in a way the
legislation
is quite conservative and it does have
to do with
how to get paychecks to people who need
it right now uh
i i want to be a little more nuanced
about
my view of mitt romney's legislation
because some conservatives are furious
at it
some very conservative people are
thrilled about it what the legislation
does is it's called the family
security act and what it proposes to do
is basically pay people to have kids
it's not quite that simple but the the
family security act
would provide a 350 per month check
to families with a child under the age
of six
and a 250 per month check to families
with a child under the age of 17. so it
goes down a little bit as they get older
in total family could receive up to 4
200 bucks per year
per child under the age of 6 and 3 000
bucks per year per child
older than six but younger than 17.
payments could start up to four months
before the baby is
due so a lot of conservatives are very
afraid of this one because it comes from
mitt romney and we're all skeptical this
is the man who invented obamacare
but also because this involves direct
payments
so you're telling me you're gonna have
the federal government just start
cutting checks to people
some conservatives especially more
social conservatives
who don't care as much about the market
stuff are thrilled about this
they say good finally we've got a
serious policy conservatives are going
to get serious about promoting families
i think the reality of this policy is
somewhere in the middle you know how
much i hate being in the middle
i think if you stand in the middle of
the road you're going to get hit by a
truck but
i i don't think we should jump on to
board with this policy right away
but i also don't think we should dismiss
it out of hand the good things about
this policy
are that it would encourage
people to have babies we need to do that
we have a dying population in this
country and a lot of our problems stem
from that
or it's a little bit of a chicken in the
egg because a lot of our social problems
are causing the decline in birth rates
but the decline in birth rates are
causing a lot of other public policy
problems like
the need for mass migration just to keep
the economy afloat those sorts of things
this sort of policy has been tried
before notably in hungary
or bonn the leader there in hungary has
tried this
he's gone even further though he's he's
offered people like
massive loans just to have kids and then
if they start if they have like more
than three kids they don't even have to
pay back the loan
uh in a way i kind of prefer that policy
to this policy there are some pitfalls
here though
one mitt romney says that this policy is
going to be deficit neutral
because it's going to we're going to fix
up some other you know welfare programs
and therefore you're not going to pay an
extra penny for it that's just
not how these programs tend to work
generally speaking
you end up spending a lot more money but
you don't make the cuts that you need to
make
but the other issue here is hungary and
the united states are different
countries hungary is a much more
conservative country in many ways than
the united states
here in the united states i could see
this opening up a whole slew of problems
namely who gets the credit
in hungary you've got to be married
you've got a you know there's a very
specific definition of marriage in
hungary
uh there it's a much more socially
cohesive sort of country than the united
states is at the moment
here could could a policy like this
encourage out of wedlock births
you know encourage people basically not
to get married
could a po could this uh encourage
single mothers to just have children on
their own by going to a sperm bank or
something like that
would this policy be applied the same
way to
a traditional marriage as it would to
say a monogamous same-sex couple
or let's say a throuple or let's say a
commune or let's say i don't know i mean
i'm being
a little outlandish here just to show
the point that
our very definition of family and
marriage is
completely in flux it's hotly debated so
a fam a family security act is going to
have to
uh answer that question first uh you
could see this
exacerbating certain social questions as
well and then there's also this problem
of getting people hooked on the
government
which is a very real problem i'm i'm not
a
free market purist in the sense that i
don't think free markets are the be all
and end all of politics i think they're
a wonderful instrument
for human flourishing and for for other
great things in politics
but you do risk something here of
getting people hooked on the government
hooked on
what would be an early version of ubi
universal basic income which is very
very bad an
inhuman sort of policy so all of that to
say i'm
believe it or not i'm actually kind of
interested in this thing mitt romney is
saying but we need to be very very
careful here we need to sort out the
details
and we can't assume anything on on the
cultural level
and we need to be very wary of getting
us hooked on these kind of economic
programs that can funnel in a lot of bad
cultural stuff
as well you know matt walsh
is going to be talking about all sorts
of all sorts of matters of family
culture from a very right-wing
perspective so make sure to check that
out live
at 1 30 eastern only at dailywire.com
the all access membership is our most
elite
membership base here at the daily wire
our all access members receive two
leftist years tumblers when they sign up
they get access to all the great daily
wire
content i can't i couldn't even begin to
describe all of it we keep adding more
and more
each day and week sometimes they tell me
you know you got to do this extra [ __ ]
you got to do that extra show you said
wait a second you haven't even given me
an extra tumbler yet
well we want to publicly thank all of
our all access members
for their commitment to the daily wire
to show our appreciation we are mailing
out
this is very very cool a special
anniversary
tumblr for all renewing all access
members this year
um uh on the front you've got the
classic leftist tears tumbler hot or
cold
with the daily wire logo on the back you
have all of our john hancocks
me ben drew matt jeremy
along with a quote kind of summing up
our our view of things here at the daily
wire
uh just a thank you to all of our access
members in particular
uh for supporting us on this five year
journey thank you very much
cheers guzzle up those cheers we'll be
right back with a lot more
we should take mitt romney's pro-family
bill
seriously we really should but we have
to work out the kinks i think there are
a lot of potential pitfalls
right now and you know if you if you
pass a
a flawed bill with this kind of an
ambition
you you could really shoot yourself in
the foot so you know take it seriously
but we got it we got to really debate
the details here
a vote that we don't really need to
debate too much that i really want us to
take immediately is from uh comes to us
from tom cotton
senator tom cotton wants democrats to go
on the record
on the question of court packing mr
president last year in certain fringe
quarters of the democratic party it
seemed popular
to call for packing the supreme court
for expanding the number of justices on
the court because you don't like their
political rulings
now obviously all republicans oppose
such a radical idea
yet many democratic politicians to
include joe biden to include
a few senators in this chamber tonight
contorted themselves to avoid taking a
position on this issue
twisting themselves into pretzels on the
campaign trail to simply say
we ought not pack the supreme court
because we don't like their rulings
so i offer a simple amendment an
amendment that is backed by famous
liberals like ruth bader ginsburg
that we should not pack the supreme
court
now i understand the democrats are going
to raise a point of order saying this is
not germaine
yet more contortions to avoid taking a
simple stance on this issue
so i would invite my democratic
colleagues who have said they don't want
to pack the court
simply waive this point of order and
let's have an up or down vote
on one of the most fundamental tenets of
the rule of law that you do not pack the
courts
because you don't like the way they roll
i yield back my time and i encourage
your support
so if if you're wondering why tom cotton
is bringing up this
vote on whether or not to pack the
supreme court seemingly at random
it's because uh without going too much
into detail this was part of a
very complicated senate process whereby
the democrats get a lot of things that
they want
but it opens up the floor to all sorts
of amendments and because the
republicans are
are not in power right now all they can
do is force democrats to take votes they
don't want to take
and so a lot of republicans were doing
this and this is
this is the vote that tom cotton was
pushing for uh
this is very important to uh
know whether or not the democrats are
gonna pack the supreme court because
we were promised before the election
promised by joe manchin we were promised
by joe biden
you know leaks that came out of the
biden campaign oh joe's not interested
in that joe doesn't want that kind of
radical policy
he wants unity and healing remember that
unity and healing
joe manchin no we're not going to pack
the core don't worry don't worry about
us
well since joe biden got into office
he has signed off on the most
radical executive orders he could have
there has been no moderation there has
been no unity in healing
joe biden then institutes a
commission to study reform to the
supreme court
all of which is a way to slowly slowly
patiently gradually try to pack the
court this is what democrats do they're
much better at it than republicans
democrats play a much longer game and by
slow walking things going gradually and
gradually and building consensus what do
they do
they radically uh overturn
so many of of our institutions and
rituals and so much of the old order
obviously they're not going to get this
vote but we we do need to keep the
pressure up on them we really need to
get these guys on the record because
the whole point of having this
commission is to
start the process now so that by the
time they do pack the court no one's
going to remember it no one's going to
pay attention
much better to get them on the record
speaking of trials by the way
we have this impeachment trial this week
i'm going to be flying actually to dc
to participate in this not not to
participate i'm not going to be uh
you know presenting any evidence or
voting or anything like that but we will
be there we're gonna be covering it with
verdict
uh which you'll recall my podcast with
senator cruz actually began last year
during the last impeachment trial but
now
a year later it's deja vu all over again
groundhog day again
and they're impeaching trump except
maybe they're not
maybe they're not because there was an
impeachment vote in the house goes to a
trial but trump's no longer president
so is it an impeachment trial or is it
not republicans have been arguing this
is unconstitutional
doesn't meet the constitutional
standards for impeachment
so far democrats have kept a unified
front but democratic senator chris
murphy
on one of the sunday shows on chris
wallace's show actually
had to admit that maybe this trial is
not constitutionally legit
i think we have a constitutional
responsibility to hold this trial
and i think you laid this out for
senator paul there is clear precedent
for the
senate moving forward on an impeachment
trial once being sent articles
even after an official has left office
and so you know my analysis here sort of
begins and ends with what is my
constitutional responsibility i don't
think our job ends just because the
president has left office in part
because
impeachment comes not only with the
provision to remove an official from
office
but to disqualify them for future office
so there's still a consequence
to president trump if convicted okay so
chris murphy gets all the democrat
talking points out at the top right yes
we have a responsibility to hold the
trial the house impeached we have a
responsibility we have to do it
the the the impeachment provision of the
constitution uh includes not just
removing a president from office but
also
preventing him from running for office
in the future you can tell how confident
democrats are that trump is unpopular
that they are desperately after he's out
of office trying to
prevent him from running again probably
because they think that no one would
vote for him right
yeah is that why not so sure about that
what he's saying here by the way is
hotly debated and i just don't think
it's true what the
impeachment provision of the
constitution says is
you will remove and prevent from running
for office in the future but you can't
remove him from office so if you can't
remove him from office
you're not fulfilling the impeachment
provision so it's not legit so you can't
prevent him from running for office
in the future the senate can't just
start taking votes and saying hey yeah
we don't like the cut of johnny's jib he
can never run for president
there are very specific criteria that
need to be followed here so after chris
murphy gets out his kind of bogus
argument and all the democratic talking
points
he's pressed further and further and
further and he does have to admit
maybe maybe this isn't quite so
constitutional as we've been pretending
it is
i will admit that this is of course a
matter of first impression
uh and so i don't think the case that
senator paul is making here is a
ridiculous one um i come to a different
judgment
i think that that clause that gives
congress the responsibility
to deny an official future office
requires us to take this step even
though the president has
left office listen to those caveats he
says the case that rand paul is making
which is the case that all
of us conservatives have been making
which is that this is not a
constitutional impeachment trial
yeah okay it's not ridiculous and then
the other caveat right at the top he
goes well look this is
this is just a matter of first
impression first impression chris
we've been talking about this for weeks
and weeks and months and months and you
impeach the guy last year probably
presumably you've thought about
the question of impeachment before why
would you say this a matter of first
impression
because you know that the argument
you're making is bogus
and you want to give yourself a little
bit of an out fair enough i mean i'm
glad you're at least
admitting that much it's more than most
democrats will do lindsey graham i think
described very well what this
impeachment is
really going to amount to which is that
it's a farce it's a partisan exercise
and it ain't going nowhere
well it's not a crime i mean the house
is impeaching him
under the theory that his speech created
a riot
when you look at the facts many people
had already planned
to attack the capitol before he ever
spoke well the trial memorandum
the trial memorandum from the house
impeachment managers actually lays out a
pattern of behavior they say it wasn't
just the speech they say this was
cultivated over time
yeah well here's what i would say that
if you believe he committed a crime
he can be prosecuted like any other
citizen
impeachment is a political process we've
never impeached a president once they're
out of office
i think this is a very bad idea uh 45
plus republicans are going to vote early
on that is unconstitutional
it's not a question of how the trial
ends
it's a question of when it ends
republicans are going to view this as an
unconstitutional
exercise and the only question is will
they call witnesses
how long does the trial take but the
outcome is really not in doubt
okay i broadly agree with lindsey graham
here he actually kind of undercut his
own argument a little bit though
and maybe he was just speaking loosely i
could i could see some ways in
some different ways to interpret that
but at the beginning right he says
what trump did is not a crime now
this is an answer to the question look
trump incited an insurrection therefore
you know you've got to impeach him right
and what lindsey graham says is no
no i lindsey graham has said i think
trump acted rashly i don't think he
should have he was irresponsible in his
language he shouldn't have said what he
said
but you can criticize the president for
the things he said between the election
and january 6th
and still conclude as i think you have
to conclude
he didn't commit any crime what crime
did he commit
first of all he didn't incite an
insurrection he said before during and
after the riot
don't be violent be peaceful much more
than you can say about democrats during
the blm riots
but what crime did he commit
so when lindsey graham at the end of
that says look impeachment's a political
process
well yes and no it's a political process
but it does have
a legal aspect too namely you need to
commit a high crime or misdemeanor
and then the political process takes
over from there
i don't even know what crime they could
accuse trump of committing
he didn't commit a crime that's the
legal aspect
then you move on to the political
question there's no way politically the
guy is going to get convicted
unless something dramatically changes
some new shocking evidence comes out
between now and and the end of the
impeachment trial quote-unquote
impeachment trial
you've already got 45 senators on the
record saying they're not going to vote
to convict
so it's just a force
so much for unity and healing why are
they why are they going forward with
this
because all we can talk about is trump
one the democrats are genuinely afraid
of trump
two the establishment needs to have
trump they love trump they need trump to
kick around they need trump
as this embodiment of evil that they can
they can go after
even joe biden is still still talking
about trump
they're so afraid of trump they're so
fascinated by trump
that joe biden was just asked on cbs
whether or not
he will extend to trump the courtesy
extended to
all former presidents in the modern era
to receive intelligence briefings joe
biden
he doesn't think that's such a good idea
should former president trump
still receive intelligence briefings
i think not why not
because of his erratic behavior
unrelated to
the insurrection i mean you've called
him an existential threat you've called
him dangerous you've called him reckless
yeah i have and i believe it what's your
worst fear if he continues to get these
intelligence briefings
i'd rather not speculate out loud i just
think that there is no
need for him to have that intelligence
briefing
what value is giving him an intelligent
briefing what impact does he have at all
other than the fact
he might slip and say something so
[Laughter]
this could be said of any former
president right bill clinton could slip
and say something think about all of the
irresponsible activities that bill
clinton has been engaging in
since he left office i'm not just
talking about going house to house
you know along with the milkman in in
chappaqua i'm also talking about
all of his foreign affairs you don't
think uh bill clinton who's
a little loose with his behavior you
don't think that's a threat
what about remember what they said about
george bush how terrible george bush was
a war criminal the democrats were
talking about that for years and years
george bush still gets his intelligence
briefings
what is it with trump they she asks him
joe what
what's your big fear here he says i'd
rather not speculate it's very clear
it's very clear what his fear is
he's afraid that trump is going to run
again against him or against
you know whoever will be running in 2024
and uh they fear that that trump could
do very well and uh
the the key attack on joe biden during
the campaign is that he was crooked he
had corrupt dealings in china
in ukraine uh through his son's shell
companies
and i have no doubt that joe biden is
very afraid that trump is going to
receive
information that could in some way
pertain to that
we we know that the uh
intelligence agencies had information
about
hunter biden's activities we know that
we know a lot of people add information
on hunter biden's activities
and perhaps joe biden's activity is
there too so he won't speculate
i wonder why maybe we can speculate why
he won't speculate
either way not not a great way to have
unity in healing you know speaking of
unity and healing
there's there's an article it's like i
don't want to spend too much time on it
but it's the craziest column i've read
in a long time and i just read the aclu
column
debunking transgender myths today this
column was in the la times called
what can you do about the trumpets next
door where
some woman says that she's a big lib
but she has these trump supporting
neighbors and they
they plow her driveway and that's very
very nice thing to do isn't it
and uh so she was thinking well i'm
grateful to them for doing this but i
still hate them because they're trump
supporters
then she compared the trump supporters
to hezbollah which
quote also gives things away for free
she then
compared her neighbors to uh louis
farrakhan who runs the nation of islam
she then compared her trump supporting
neighbors who played her driveway to the
nazis
who uh who were sometimes said to be
very polite
nazis can be polite too and so she
uh you know still hates her neighbors
but she's willing to get her driveway
plaid
we've said this time and time again on
this show
the only way we get unity and healing is
if the left wants to have unity and
healing
your opponent in politics and war your
opponent gets a say
and they they do not want unity and
healing right now it would seem
and so we're at a stalemate we can't
force it we can't force it we just have
to deal in the realities
that we are living in no matter how much
squishy republicans want to suck up
to democrats it's going to be up to
democrats to come
and try to unify the country too right
now they have no desire
to do that
you know i was recently rereading edmond
burke reflections on the revolution in
france
and one of the great great conservative
works of all time edmund burke credited
with founding modern conservatism
and uh berks burke's attack
on france there are many attacks he
makes on france but one of them is that
the revolutionaries there they
destroyed all the old traditions they
destroyed all the old
laws they destroyed even the old
neighborhoods the old
way to sort of the geography to divvy up
the whole country
he says the french revolutionaries
treated their own country in the way
that other nations have treated
conquered lands
the french revolutionaries treated their
own people
in the way that prior
war mongers prior conquerors would have
treated
subjugated peoples but they did it to
themselves this act of
masochism this act of sort of national
suicide
hard not to see the parallels to the
modern left
which deplores our
nation's traditions deplores our
nation's history hates our nation's
founding fathers
tears down statues of the great men who
built this country
and also deplores the american people
themselves i use
deplore intentionally that's the word
that hillary clinton used to refer to
half of her countrymen deplorable
irredeemable even when we plow their
snow out of their driveways they call us
nazis
on the pages of the la times this isn't
even some fringe lady i mean
they're behaving like fringe people but
this is a very mainstream person writing
in
the la times saying yeah thanks for
playing my driveway but you're still a
nazi
bad state bad state for the country and
it uh
in in that sort of situation
reconciliation
coming together meeting in the middle
probably not a great plan
if you've got two people who you know
they both love their country
one has one vision for the country one
has another vision of the country but
they both really love the country they
both wave the american flag
coming together meeting in the middle
that might not be the worst idea
but when you've got one person who loves
the country one person who hates the
country
meeting in the middle is a very very bad
idea that you can't you actually can't
meet in the middle there is no middle
there
there's there can be no neutrality
between you like your country or you
hate your country what you just feel
indifferent about your country
not how politics works politics does not
work on indifference
the one way i i try when i can
to have a little unity in healing you
know obviously not on matters of the
kind of substantive policy or supporting
these politicians but i actually i will
just just in that spirit trying hoping
beyond hope
to bring our country together i will
sort of defend joe biden a very very
limited way in a very
specific way joe biden just did this
interview
on kovid and he's being attacked
for apparently engaging in sexism uh
take a listen to what he said see if you
consider this
sexist support
are you a freshman at the university no
no you look like a freshman
well thank you now thank you for what
you're doing
it really matters as i said uh
to the doc last a few moments ago dr
chris
so joe biden he's talking to this nurse
and he says are you a freshman at the
university
you look like a freshman number of
commentators
uh actually especially conservatives are
calling this exchange
sexist i think that's pushing it
you know i think what happened here is
that joe biden
told a woman that she looks young
and she giggled and said thank you
he paid her a compliment wasn't
licentious i don't think joe was trying
to pick the woman up
i think he's an old guy and he and he
told a woman that she looks young
which is a nice thing to do it's nice
when men compliment women
it's a good thing it's kind of nice when
women compliment men too
the compliment complementarity of the
sexes is actually a really nice thing
it's been at the center of civilization
for a very long time if joe biden had
been sort of licentious or something
like that about it then maybe you could
make a case but
he wasn't he was just saying to say that
this is sexist
i guess in a very basic way it's sexist
because it's saying men and women are
different
men and women men can complement women
women complement men men talk to women a
little bit differently than women talk
to men
maybe men use sort of vulgar crass
language with other men at the bar but
they don't use that kind of language
with women yeah
men and women are different isn't that
how we started the show
men and women are different isn't that a
central cultural issue of our time
what the left is saying going actually
going back to the
feminists even now we're talking about
gender ideology but going back to
feminism too
the premise there is that there is no
significant difference between men and
women
yeah maybe a couple appendages look a
little different but you know
basically there's no significant
difference
that's the leftist view the conservative
view is men and women are different
men are from mars women are from venus
and you know the difference between men
and women is that it's actually a
beautiful thing it's really nice
something we ought to respect something
we ought to take delight in it's one of
the joys of life
but joe biden here unwittingly just
because he's an old guy and he was
paying a compliment
was was demonstrating that i don't want
to attack him for it i think it's a sort
of a nice thing
he's also just a sort of back slapper
politician right that's what he does
what
joe biden does is hey you're looking
great i love that baby
vote for me i'm old joe from scranton
another ridiculous thing that people are
upset about
and from another politician who's sort
of a nice guy and has an every man
appeal
is ron desantis ron desantis was
watching the super bowl and
uh he was not wearing a mask
and so ron desantis there's some chatter
about this he goes up to a reporter
afterward and he says you're going to
ask me why i wasn't wearing a mask
reporter says yes he says i wasn't
wearing a mask because how the hell am i
going to be able to drink a beer with a
mask on
got to drink a beer while i'm watching
my team win
so sorry that's the way it goes
similar kind of backslappy vibe i i
really liked that answer
very practical very uh prudent of course
that's the case
ron desantis is clearly eyeing the white
house for 2024.
i'm getting strong uh christy 2012 vibes
from him
i'm not you know people's if you compare
a guy to chris christie people now feel
offended but
christy in 2012 was actually a very
strong candidate
and this idea was a state politician he
was good he was tough he was practical
he said it like it is you know he's not
going to talk in political
gobbledygook ron desantis would seem to
be running in that lane
right now very practical kind of stuff
you see a the pie in the sky kind of
abstract politics that we've seen on the
right for a long
time that has uh gone away i think i
don't think that's the future of the
republican party i think the future of
the republican party
is going to be calling out basic truths
running against political correctness in
the same way that trump did in the same
way that christie
did same way that ron desantis seems to
be doing so
it's going to be talking directly to the
practical concerns of people in the way
that romney i think is actually trying
to do
that's going to be the future you
couldn't you couldn't name more
different politicians than all of those
guys
but they're all seeing that's kind of
the way forward there's something very
very
conservative about that saying basic
truths talking to the needs of people
and being
prudent now is that is that going to
sell for us winning forward
i will have to get prudent about how
elections are conducted and have
integrity too
but that could be a vision for a
political future i'm michael nolis the
michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show